у
Віктора розкритикували роль Росії в
українській кризі що означає Україна для
Росії чому виник такий конфлікт довкола
України
з
європейськими цінностями
які
відрізняються від європейських західне
у визнавати різницю цих цінностей і
всі задоволені але ми через це втратили
величезну довіру заходу Ну
а в
заходу була велика довіра до Росії та ми
взагалі втратили ще безліч різних речей
і ще довго-довго це відчувати Крим
обійшовся у дуже і копнув ногою
він
дуже Образився на захід який підтримав
протестний рух
вони цілувалися обнімалися
гуляли скрізь А потім з'ясувалося що
німці сказали Ми дуже любимо протести
рух який узагалі хотів його вигнати у
Магадан або посадити в тюрму Вінск
а зрадники ви вас хотів Я буду будувати
імперію тепер і піду з Китаєм дружити а
тут Україно йому сказала що ми не хочемо
будувати велику імперію а
о.в.